he's Yahoo Sports national college
columnist his latest column why the NCAA
tournament's expansion to 68 teams has
not worked out pat 14 joins us on
program ready to go to Duke and North
Carolina on Saturday good morning Pat
good morning Dan I hope Zion Williamson
was ready to go to Duke and North
Carolina on Saturday well he'll be there
he just won't be in uniform I don't care
yeah yeah it's been become a real
buzzkill to the most interesting story
in college basketball here see if he
hopefully is back next week for the ACC
tournament and I'm wondering the
importance of how do plays in that ACC
tournament because if Virginia and North
Carolina have number one seeds in
Gonzaga you know what's the chance Duke
is not a number one seed come tournament
time oh it's it's escalating I think
every every game he doesn't play and
they look as bad as they did they were
really lucky to be a terrible Wake
Forest team without him and you know if
there's any chance he's not 100 percent
of the NCAA tournament if I'm selection
committee I'm looking and saying this
team isn't that great without him so I
think he needs to play and needs to play
at a level that suggests that he's back
you know so I think there's a little bit
of sense of urgency there obviously you
know yeah they can get away with it
without playing him Saturday in Chapel
Hill although that would be ashamed to
basically play 30 seconds of your entire
career against North Carolina you know
but then the ACC tournament he
absolutely needs to play all right
handicap this Virginia number one seed
Gonzaga number one seed North Carolina
have to beat Duke to be a number one
seed I think so you know I think right
now I I mean I I still would have Duke
on the one line just because I think
that they've lost one game with their
with their full team but if North
Carolina beats them then I would
probably put North Carolina up there and
then it's a Kentucky Tennessee LSU tapi
poll probably for the fourth one if if
Dukes out of the picture what's going on
with the SEC with basketball they become
a basketball conference here
how about that it's uh it's been wildly
entertaining I mean a crazy crazy season
LSU you know they have to do is beat
last place Vandy on Saturday and they
win the league at least to share the
league in that the number one seed for
the for the SEC Tournament and they've
played seven games in overtime I mean it
doesn't matter who they play every games
going down to the wire they've had you
know these crazy finishes their head
coach is being subpoenaed to go to a
federal trial in April it has not been
dull with LSU and then you know
Tennessee and Kentucky have taken turns
blowing each other out I think after
that the league's pretty ordinary but at
the top with these three it's really
interesting I'm gonna go to that
tournament next week I'm very interested
to see those three teams play what about
that what happen to the pac-12 or the
artist formerly known as it's it's a
train wreck it's it's worse in
basketball than it was in football which
is saying something you know I think
they've had a real coaching low
obviously they've had a recruiting low
there's just not as many good players
than out there you know Arizona cratered
after the federal basketball scandal
implicated them heavily and they'll a
lot of their recruits that went
elsewhere would have been there this
year USC is massively underachieved UCLA
as Maskelyne underachieved
Oregon had Bulbul via the seven-foot one
player Manute Bol son who's supposed to
be really good who got hurt early I mean
everybody stinks it's a bad bad league
they'll be lucky if they get to bits
what do you hear about UCLA their
coaching search not much at this point
it stayed pretty vague and pretty quiet
you know I think obviously there's been
a lot of speculation about Luke Walton
because they for either of two jobs
because Arizona could be opening as well
you know it's not exactly the good ship
lollipop in Los Angeles and so if he's
out there and if he wants to go to
college I think you could have his pick
between those two there's been some
people that have pushed for
beti no I don't see that happening at
UCLA but there's been some people
there's a lot at least Lobby did loved
his name out there yeah I talked to a
guy whose job is to find coaches for
jobs so that's his job
and I was talked to him about Tony
Bennett going to UCLA what do you think
about that possibility well I mean that
would be a humongous homerun I think for
UCLA
you know his style of play is not the
most wildly entertaining and they have
been massive March flops but still if
you want to win 30 games which I would
think everybody does and you know win
pac-12 titles that's not a bad place to
start
and he was very successful out there
when he was at Washington State you know
I he I don't know how much really
stocked to put into that whole you know
line of thinking that if you're in Los
Angeles you want to get attention you've
got to be entertaining he wouldn't fit
that mold either personally or
stylistically for his team but I think
he'd win a lot of games
yeah but USC style is supposed to be
entertaining and that doesn't matter
like I I just want you to at this point
I think UCLA's got to realize that
they're not UCLA of old and these you
know these coaches are looking at this
going I don't need to go there I can do
this at Virginia and still get paid well
and you know I don't need to follow in
the John Wooden footsteps here sure yeah
and there's still people around that
think that you know John Wooden was
coaching there you know three weeks ago
it's not the case and quite frankly the
last successful since they had Ben
Howland you played it pretty played a
pretty Bennett ball kind of style you
know were they won game 62 55 so if you
want to win they could do a lot worse
but yeah that job is has lost a lot of
luster it's not the same as what it was
but a lot of people really don't kind of
realize that and still think that you
know UCLA should be able to snap its
fingers and win national championships
this hadn't happened in a long long time
if I gave you Duke or the field knowing
Zions going to play and be healthy
I'd probably still take the field I
would have been close to taking Duke
versus the field a few weeks ago I don't
know I did I got to see it I think I
have to see it here before I fill out my
bracket and say I'll take Duke versus 67
other teams so if if he is healthy and
he is he can just eat he's back to just
tearing the rim down and you know
jumping over the backboard and doing all
the great things he does III would feel
very comfortable picking him to win the
tournament still another I want to pick
him at the exclusion of everyone else
yeah I would take the field I just think
that you know that outside shooting if
if you can write you know contain them
and make them shoot that that jumper
then you can knock them off and and we
know on a neutral site somebody
somebody's gonna have a great night
shooting it you're against them and then
force them to shoot threes and they just
can't shoot those threes so I I would
take the field I am curious though you
said the NCAA tournament's expansion to
68 teams has not worked out I did you
know I just well first of all I think it
was it was a complete cop-out just to
bow to the pressure from power
conferences to say our 7th 8th to 9th
place teams need to make this tournament
so let's let's let's put them in that's
really what it's done I crunched some
numbers on it and 56% of those first
four bids you know not counting the 16
seats that they make play against each
other and sort of letting them get their
chance to be UMBC but the other games
56% of them are from power five comp our
six conferences if you include the big
feast that's a higher percentage than
the overall power six representation in
the bracket so we're of those bids gone
basically that's who they've gone to to
you know a USC team it's no good to a
seat and whole team that's no good - eh
you know mid-level big 10 PAC club or
sec whatever I don't want to see those
teams in the tournament that's not
helping make the tournament any better
to me I don't need games on Tuesday and
Wednesday to make the tournament better
I don't need those teams you know then
playing and scurrying off somewhere else
the tournament was perfect at 64 to me
expanding to
the egg was just rewarding mediocrity
safe travels therefore a Duke North
Carolina and we'll catch up with you
during the tournament Thank You Pat all
right thank you Dan that's Pat 40 yahoo
sports national college columnist for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]